encouragement affirmation it's the
oxygen of the soul
it feeds us it takes us and
gives us hope confidence is in your
calendar baby
your confidence is in your calendar
manage your calendar well
and progress comes in focus is power but
you gotta take it
take it back take back that power wanna
be happy
build a life not just a business
[Music]
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you've got
something more inside you you've got
michael jordan level of genius at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn the 10 secrets
that if you apply for the next seven
days
will change your life enjoy
okay let's kick it off with secret
number one rest and renew with robin
sharma
every day work for five hours the five
great hours concept
and then pull back and have fun rest
renew and then every week take a weekend
off every month try to take a week off
every year try to take two
two months off and the interesting thing
is number one
rest is the elite performers secret
weapon number two this is so important
if you want to get more more done take
more time off
because if you're working 24 7
in a linear way versus like a pulse
what starts to happen is you erode and
deplete
your genius and in my methodology i
teach
the five assets of genius including
mental focus
physical energy three personal willpower
but just remember if all you do is work
you're gonna
empty your batteries you're gonna
deplete your well
and that's why the smartest performers
you know the great athletes the the the
great industry titans the great
humanitarians
these people all have learned one thing
work
in cycles if you were to look at the
the great weightlifter weight lifters of
the olympics
they all had one thing in common and it
was periodization
periodization and periodization
simply means they worked they exercised
and then they rested
secret number two use time well with
brendan burchard
if i want to be confident i must feel
like i'm capable
if i want to feel capable i must feel
like i'm contributing i must challenge
myself
and as you also heard in previous videos
i had to be honest about my day and my
schedule in my life because
i faced the end of my life you know i
had that car accident as a young man
that made me realize
life is so short and i always tell
people
if you believe life is short you
probably believe life is precious right
so you should be grateful for life right
well i tell people all the time
you know where real gratitude shows up
real gratitude shows up in your calendar
because if you're really thankful for
life you're using your time
well my friend if you really care about
life
you use time well but most people don't
so they're not getting progress
because they're not getting progress
they don't feel that sense of
accomplishment achievement contribution
because they don't feel achievement
contribution and progress
they feel down on themselves they feel
less
worthy less capable and they trust in
themselves and their future less
because they're not making it happen
confidence is not only your belief in
your ability to figure things out
confidence is that sense of your own
worth your own ability
your own future and if you keep throwing
away days
of course you don't feel amazing about
yourself
so we gotta get organized and
disciplined right but think of how many
people
don't manage their lifo i mean do let's
do some math together
you know today do you think maybe this
morning let's say before noon
uh you lost like 20 minutes
of focus or productivity somewhere you
know maybe you
did something that wasn't really
developing yourself or wasn't something
that needed to be created
and you got distracted on some social
media thing or or
you know maybe just you were paying
attention and you lost some time
well let's do some math 20 minutes lost
just in any given morning over the
course of seven days
well it's 140 minutes isn't it 140
minutes is
almost two and a half hours well over
the course of four weeks
that's over eight hours lost
meaning you lost an entire eight
hour work day every month by just losing
what 20 minutes in the morning but you
know most people
they're losing more than that maybe they
lose an hour in the morning
and if they lose an hour in the morning
that means they lost
four work days
per year i mean per month four work days
per month
think about that so people say i don't
have time or something no
it's like when we don't use our time
well we're stealing from our own
confidence
when we don't use our time well we're
stealing from our ability to serve
when we don't use our time well we're
not going to make that dent in the
universe change the world to make more
money for your family
you're going to be more disorganized and
because you're more disorganized you're
always last minute because you're last
minute you can't plan trips with your
family and your friends
you don't plan your working project as
much and i know it doesn't seem like so
much but i always tell people
your confidence is in your calendar baby
your confidence is in your calendar
manage your calendar well and progress
comes in it's like oh when you're doing
things
consistently that matter to you your
brain goes hey
i had this intention i'm doing it i feel
confident
so today i want you to decide to retake
your agenda your life schedule
what are some things you need to
immediately stop doing in your life
they are time suck they are not
passionate they are not moving you
forward but you keep getting distracted
there like what do you need to stop
doing is it watching seven seasons of a
show
you know every week is it like what are
you gonna do to get your time back is it
like minimizing the amount of you know
useless chit chat that doesn't add to
anything in your life like
is it social media is it tv is it just
not being organized like what
what do you need to stop doing to take
back control of life
also what do you need to start doing and
what you need to start doing every day
every week every month every year to be
on your a game
as an example many of you know i
personally fill out my high performance
planner
every single day i create it for my
greatest clients
based off the world's largest study of
high performers
and this is how they think in the
morning so i do all these mindset
prompts so i get my mind right because
in the morning i don't know about you
i'm kind of a nutty professor in the
morning i like wander around
and just like what am i going to do and
i just i'm like i'm a free spirit in the
morning
but i had this one client one time she's
a really famous yoga teacher
and i was working with her and she said
well brand i just like to be a free
spirit in the morning i said yeah i said
is there anything you know in your life
that you wish you could do but you can't
do because you're so busy
oh yeah you know there's this yoga
retreat coming up i don't have any time
for it
i said oh poor free spirit don't have
time for a yoga retreat
well maybe you would have time for a
yoga retreat if you organize yourself a
little bit in the morning
because see discipline buys you freedom
to do what you want
so confidence is in the calendar like
take back
your life and get a little more
organized and you have more free time
get a little more organized you serve
better serve better make more money like
these things all add together i know you
know that
all right my friend evan carmichael's
book listen humans are built to serve
some people are built to serve the world
others
want to serve the 25 people closest to
them but in either case humans are built
to serve so if you're not happy right
now
it's because you're not serving enough
you got to pick up this book because
it's so inspiring to remind you that
we're all here to contribute to make a
difference to make an impact and this
is your field guide for that secret
number three
write it down with marie forleo dr gail
matthews who's a professor of psychology
at the dominican university of
california she did this
amazing study on goal setting right and
she discovered this
that we human beings are actually 42
percent
more likely to achieve our goals if we
simply write them down look
i know y'all i know this sounds basic
but people
still don't have their top goals written
down and i gotta tell you they certainly
don't look at them
every day so here's what i do this is my
own personal practice
whatever my top goals are for the moment
i actually
write each one of them down i do this
every day and i write them down
at least 15 times this is exactly what i
did when it came to my book
everything is figureoutable i literally
wrote i am a number one new york times
bestseller
15 times a day every single day for 18
months
now you can say what you want about that
whether it's voodoo
i think it's all about focus so if you
think i'm nuts i'm fine with that most
people do
but once i did this every single day it
helped me
keep my top focus top of mind
right so you can do this too and if
you're truly serious about achieving
your goals this year
please make sure that you actually write
them down and i would encourage you to
write them down daily secret number four
do it now with tony robbins
it's not necessarily there are more
demands it's just that we're accessible
to more demands
and if you don't know what you want and
you don't know why it's a must for you
to achieve it and you don't have a plan
i can promise you something you're going
to fit in everybody else's plan
and you're going to wonder why you're
stressed and you're going to wonder why
i'm not fulfilled
what is time how do you know when it's a
long time or how do you know when it's a
short time it's not because it's 10
minutes or 10 hours
how many been in 10 hours and time flew
because you loved what you're doing
didn't have any sense of time whatsoever
how many had that experience say aye
how many have had 10 minutes feel like
10 years you want to kill somebody to
get out of the situation
so what is time time is emotion
got to remember that time is emotion
what you're really managing
is emotion another word for that would
be meaning
or fulfillment focus is
power but you got to take it take it
back take back that power
and you got to know when you do have
that focus how to chunk it how to group
it so you're not overwhelmed let me show
you how to
make it simpler when mass information is
coming at you
you get overwhelmed most of us
are great deletion creatures we delete
most of life right now there are
millions of things around you you could
be focusing on thinking about giving
meanings to
making decisions about what to do
millions and when you think about what
it's going to take to do something
usually it takes a lot and you're not
going to want to do it so i'll do it
when
later because my australian friends
would say later
right and of course the problem with
doing it tomorrow is when you get to
tomorrow tomorrow is today
tomorrow never comes so and you keep
promising yourself by the way what does
this do to you emotionally when you keep
breaking your own promises with yourself
or you keep failing to do things that
you know are important
does it increase your level of certainty
and confidence
no what it does is it wrote it when you
wrote confidence in one area believe it
or not it affects the other areas too
do you believe me on that don't believe
me what about your own life experience
secret number five make a commitment
with john ashraf
the question is why do we
choose low value or low income or
low impact producing activities
instead of the high impact high income
high value producing activities every
single day
well the answer is twofold number one
it's because we've gotten into the habit
of doing the small menial unimportant
things
first thinking that being busy
is the same as being productive that's
number one
number two in most cases procrastination
is caused
by insecurity us either not knowing what
steps to take
us not feeling like we are smart enough
or good enough
or us feeling that we have to wait for
everything to be perfect
before we really get busy and do it
the truth of the matter is those are all
lies they're rational lies
but they're all lies what i want you to
do from now on
is every morning when you wake up before
you answer email before you return any
phone calls
make a short list of the three
most important things that are either
highest income for you or highest impact
meaning it's going to give you the
biggest
impact when you get that done on your
productivity so
three things every day and make a
commitment
which means to cut off from any other
option to get those three things done
by 12 o'clock every day
when you develop that new habit you will
then become
somebody who not only talks a big talk
which i hope you do
but you actually back it up with the
actions required
in order to achieve the success you want
to achieve
what i've learned over a lot of years is
that it's not the smartest people who
achieve
success it's the people who
procrastinate less
make fewer excuses as they take
actions every day towards the goals that
they want to achieve
secret number six encourage more with
john maxwell
i want to talk about a principle today
of
affirmation because i believe that
people
do best in an encouraging affirming
environment i just do very seldom i've
ever had a person say
let me tell you really how i achieved
great success
i just was in a constant negative
environment and
it just encouraged me so much and it
just stirred me up
very seldom i've ever had somebody tell
me that when people talk
down to them it just improved them
you see encouragement affirmation it's
the oxygen of the soul
it feeds us it takes us and
gives us hope and napoleon said leaders
are all dealers in hope
and so the affirmation principle is very
simple
i find something that you're doing well
and i use that to lead you
i use that as the starting place and i
look at you and say hey
i like what you did there let's talk
about it a little bit
let's even talk about maybe how next
time you can do it
better my friend ken blanchard
made the phrase management by walking
around kind of a popular phrase and
basically
he just said walk through the office and
catch somebody doing something good and
point to it
affirm it and and build off of it now
there are people that do things that are
not so good and there are times in
leadership
you have to deal with the tough issues
i'm not saying that
but what i'm saying is this people go
farther
do better and try harder in an
affirming encouraging environment so
the best that you can do is to
constantly look for those
good moments and make them better
that's what an affirming environment is
all about
looking for the good moments and making
them better
trust me you do that a few times and
people will want you to walk around
they'll want you to catch them in their
good moments because they know that's
where they'll get encouraged
and that's where they'll get affirmed
secret number seven analyze your daily
activities with dean graziosi
so many of you are working your asses
off you guys are putting the energy the
effort
the thinking energy the physical energy
the time the effort
but are you really managing your actions
to make sure that every day
even if it's just an hour a day if
you've got to work most of the day
to pay the bills and keep things going
or keep your company going
that's okay but you need to designate
an hour a half hour two hours whatever
you can spare
on the things that can actually move the
needle towards your next level
towards your goals what can you work on
that actually moves the needle that
you're not we get sucked into busy work
sometimes our brains allows us to say no
but i'm busy i'm busy i'm busy
but are you productive busy and
productivity have nothing to do with
each other you can run on a treadmill
as fast as you want a number 10 for an
hour you're still not getting anywhere
you're in one spot going fast your heart
was racing you're feeling like
but you didn't get anything done you
didn't accomplish anything you didn't
move the needle
i want you to think in brackets of yes
and no
black or white needle movers
not needle movers energy energy draining
like what i want you to think about for
the next six months and listen
of course there are some gray areas but
what if you got more black and white
binary a one or an o an x or a zero a
yes or no black or white like nothing in
between because
if you start analyzing some of the
things that you do
on a daily basis and literally say does
this
drain my energy or enhance my energy it
drains it
it's got to go does this actually move
the needle
in my business or not if i've been
spending months trying to figure out the
right color and the logo
and what should i do an llc or an s-corp
should i buy a dot-com or a net and
should i should i promote on instagram
or maybe more facebook if you spend the
last three months six months focusing on
that
you're busy but you're not focusing on
the needle mover so think
is this energy this this focus this time
i'm spending
does it make my business make me more
money or not make me more money if it
doesn't
decide to get rid of it or change it if
if you're gonna focus on things am i
gonna is it does it help my marketing or
does it help my marketing
does it allow me to grow or not grow
does it allow me to make
impact or no impact
does this person light me up or bring me
down
what if for the next six months of your
life
you created a habit of being less gray
less gray matter it's black or white
it's yes or no
it's a hell yes or i ain't doing it
secret number eight
allow time for distraction with j shetty
when i'm having a productive effective
day that doesn't mean i don't get
distracted i get distracted plenty of
times i have tons of notifications
social media big announcements things
that are happening
throughout the day plus a team across
the world
in different time zones to manage so
when i get distracted
i've created a really healthy
relationship with distraction
i feel like sometimes our relationship
with distraction is quite negative we
see it as a bad thing we
judge ourselves for feeling distracted
we start saying
oh i wish i was more focused or i wish i
was more effective
so i literally got one of these
distraction timers as i call it
and i turn it over as soon as i get
distracted i let the sand run out and as
soon as it runs out i have to get back
to my task
this gives me the space and the time to
allow for little distractions
and now i figured out a way to allow
myself five minutes of distraction time
every hour so every hour i allow myself
to browse on my phone for two to five
minutes
and that way i know that that time is
going to happen that time is going to
come
and that allows me to delay it to put it
off and to postpone
my own distractions secret number nine
stick on new behaviors
any behavior any behavior needs a
trigger
right so um you talking to me now
we had an appointment there would have
been some trigger it could have been
your memory
it could have been a notification on
your phone it could have been your pa
phoning you it would have required a
trigger of some
sort now when it comes to triggers
that's kind of three broad types right
one is your memory right so your memory
works
like it could be oh i heard that podcast
meditation is really important
so you go the next day you think yeah i
heard that on impact theory i need to
meditate
oh you're waiting for your memory to
remind you now that may work if you
remember every day you may end up
meditating
but it's very unreliable so the next
best form of trigger
is some kind of notification it could be
notification on your phone
it could be a post-it note on your
refrigerator
or on your laptop reminding you to do
something
that is better than memory but it's not
as good as the final type of trigger
which is when you stick on that new
behavior
onto an existing habit because that
habit by definition
means you're already doing it without
thinking about it i'll give you an
example
that i do so i don't go to the gym
i've not been to the gym probably for
about two years but i stay fit
right i do a workout every morning so
what happens in the morning i do a
couple of things as part of my routine
but the second thing i do
is i make coffee right so in the kitchen
i'll weigh out the coffee beans i'll
pour it into the french press and the
timer goes on for four to five minutes
during that time i don't go on instagram
i don't go on email i don't make phone
calls
i do a workout in the kitchen in my
pajamas
right i've stuck it on to that behavior
so every morning i'm going to have
coffee so every morning i work out i
don't need to find
time in my day to do it i'm not saying
that's going to work for anyone else but
it works for me
and that's what people have to do they
have to find what are those existing
habits in their life
that they can stick on new behaviors to
so
if we apply that to something like a tea
ritual
okay so i know that my wife and i we
know that our relationship is better
when we commit to that tea ritual every
day and actually in during covert in the
first few weeks of lockdown
we actually stopped doing it our whole
patterning had gone our rhythm had gone
and we noticed the subsequent decline in
the
intimacy and the quality of our
relationship so again i wouldn't call
that failure i call that education it's
not
you know every time you stop doing
something and you're in tune with
the impact it's like ah you know what
when we do those five minutes
a day actually our relationship is much
better we feel closer we feel connected
and why is five minutes important right
the five minutes it's not a gimmick
right
but the five minutes is the commitment
we make to each other
so why five minutes are so powerful is
that it's small enough that even the
busiest person
feels that i can fit that into my day
it's only five minutes
and secret number 10 the last one before
a very special bonus clip
is boost your energy with mel robbins
the reason why you assess your energy
is because if you boost your energy
first thing
it impacts your productivity all day and
so to feel more energized what can i do
because if you wake up feeling
you're going to feel out of control well
there's things i can do i can take time
for myself today i can listen to music
i can call somebody that makes me laugh
all things that will boost my energy
immediately in fact
just scheduling in the time ahead today
to do those things
will boost my energy immediately that's
important because
it snaps my mind back in focus despite
what's going on around me and helps me
take control of my day
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and what is your plan of action for the
next week the sign says that when you
just watch a video you get motivated you
get inspired you have a 35
chance of actually doing something
following through that believe nation
is not enough 35 is not enough we got to
do something but when you get inspired
by watching a video like this
and then you create a plan of action
your chances of following
will jump to 91 and when you commit
publicly
like putting your comment down below
with your plan it jumps in 95
that's what i want for you i want you to
take action your dreams are too
important
your life matters your mission has to
happen
so question of the day your biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week put it down in the comments below
and i'm going to celebrate alongside
with you what do you say when you see
yourself in the mirror
when it's just you when you're all alone
it's just you you see yourself in the
mirror
what do you say do you say great things
or do you beat yourself up
most people they might act confident and
seem like they have it all put together
but secretly they're fighting their own
battles and at home
in private the comfort of their own home
they're their own worst enemies
the secret is to be your own biggest
critic as well as your biggest fan
the push you give yourself has to be
from a place of love and potential
not lack and despair so i recently
posted on instagram
a little cartoon of me passing by a
mirror and you see my reflection in the
mirror
and the caption says i love you and then
i challenge people to say hey what do
you what do you say to yourself when you
look in the mirror
and giving them an 18-day challenge to
say every time you see a reflection of
yourself
to say something positive whether it's i
love you or give yourself a compliment
something positive because i think most
people live in the land of negativity
all we see is all the
negative things that we're doing and all
the things that didn't work out and
things that could have been better
and that can actually be very healthy i
think you need to be your own biggest
critic i think you need to have
higher standards for yourself than what
you're currently doing but it
only works being your own biggest critic
only works when it's based off a
foundation of
love when it's based on a foundation of
i am an amazing human being and i love
myself
and i suck at all of these skills the
problem that most people have is you see
that you suck at a skill that you didn't
get the result that you're not good on
camera the first time you go out
you didn't get the result you didn't
land the sale you didn't make the deal
you didn't get the date
you know whatever it is you didn't get
the result and then you think that you
suck as a human because you don't have
the skills
it's the opposite you're you're amazing
as a human
it has to be from a foundation of love
and every day for the next 18 days
you challenge yourself that whenever i
see myself reflective surface
a mirror the cell phone whatever i'm
going to say something positive to
myself
in fact just make that your cell phone
background and that
when you see your your login screen or
your home screen on your cell phone
background on your desktop
it says something positive about you and
it's a reminder i have to say something
positive about myself
just for 18 days try it flex the x
challenge why 18 days because it takes
at least 18 days to build a habit
science says that it takes 18 to 254
days to build a habit that's why i have
my 254 series because i'm there with you
every step of the way
and the average is actually 66 days of
consecutive action it means no time off
no days off to build the habit
but the minimum is 18 days so just try
it for 18 days
just try what's gonna happen in 18 days
the worst is you're saying something you
don't believe about yourself for 18 you
can handle it
you'll be okay the best case scenario is
you actually start to love yourself a
little bit more
and the things that you can do when you
believe in yourself and you love
yourself
are tremendous
[Music]
if you want five powerful habits that
you should copy
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll love it continue to
believe
and i'll see you there one of the best
things i've learned
is that anyone has what it takes to
travel
the hard road to walk the path that
leads
to success i have a self-talk